très énervé bah oui et qu'est ce que tu
fais compter énervé alors mais chez moi
c'est moi voir comment tu fait les gros
yeux
moi j'aimerai pas être ton amoureux
parce qu'ils
[Musique]
devaient
même où mènera
[Musique]
à la bénisse thème mai
[Rires]
ce maillot
bonjour à tous alors vous vous posez
peut-être la question mais comment on
fabrique les cartes de la météo que je
vais vous lui montrez nous sommes ici à
l'infographie alors voilà le document
que nous envoie météo france à savoir la
carte du matin et de l'après-midi - là
dessus j'ai écrit des chiffres et des
lettres le graphiste après en fonction
de ce que j'ai écrit va chercher les
nuages qui correspondent aux différentes
lettres pour après les appliquer sur la
carte maintenant on est en train de
placer les différents hôpitaux qui
représente les averses les orages les
nuages pour un autre logiciel pour
animer les cartes et on voit très bien
l'évolution des zones entre le matin et
l'après midi en moyenne le temps qu'il
faut pour préparer une carte du matin la
carte de l'après-midi et l'évolution
entre le matin et l'après midi c'est à
peu près trois heures de travail
koita pas famille soit papa revient
faire un bisou à papa oh
je vais bien papa
oh lala com assure qui je suis tombé à
cannes